[Music]
elsa is with us in delray beach florida
hi elsa what's up
hey dave hey george i'm so excited to
speak with you and i'm excited in
general cool um so the reason i'm
calling is because i was recently
catapulted into baby step seven
and i feel like i should know what to do
but i kind of feel a little paralyzed
with the economy so i have about a
hundred thousand dollars
um that i think
so this is something with and i just
kind of want to
be as a pros and just hear that out loud
i should be doing with this money okay
how did you get catapulted
so um i was married and now i'm not and
it's for good reasons it was long
overdue and
i uh we owed a little bit on the primary
residence which i ended up keeping
and um owed a little on a car and
we sold um a home in um our old like
area that we lived in and the net of
everything just caused everything to get
paid off and then i met it a hundred
thousand when everything was said and
done
wow okay
how old are you
um 24. say again
44. 44. what do you do for a living
i'm in advertising
what do you make
125 good for you well done awesome okay
so you're 44 um newly single 100 debt
free you make a hundred and some odd
thousand bucks
and uh houses paid for and everything
and you got 100 grand in your pocket
yeah wow
good problem to have sounds like the
future's bright to me
where do i go do i put it in the market
like you know kind of are you happy with
the
i am and um i have a son who's 11 so i
want to stay here for now because his
schools and i want to keep the
consistency there so yeah i am happy
with the house great you got anything
safe for for college yet you started
that
yep college stuff is being saved for um
putting 15 in retirement i have um some
old iras which i actually have um with
an investment pro that i got through um
you know the the
elps
and um
you know he actually
ironically just called me and told me he
was switching on brokerage houses and
said you know he knew that this home was
actually pending jail for um a long time
that it was going to be sold
so i told him it's like your timing's
perfect um and he's like all right cool
like let's you know set you up we'll get
your money market account and we can do
this and then i'm just like nervous
because
just what they've just said like we're
going into a recession and we could be
going into words when do you think
you'll use the money the hundred
thousand dollars
i don't that's the thing i don't have
any and i also and the other so you feel
like you got at least five years that
you won't need it
probably and i also have like prob once
when my budget is said and done i should
be netting about three to four thousand
dollars a month that i can put away as
well but
my point is if you leave it alone five
years
if you look back at the history of the
market
uh 96 of the five-year periods in the
market's history have made money
right
and so that means the market's on sale
right now because it's down
um
now you've been through a lot personally
you're a newly single mom with an 11
year old
this mess you've just been through the
heart-wrenching anger the heartbreak the
emotions
and now you're the other side of it and
there's this strange calm after the
storm which is also a little bit
unsettling
all of that enters into the equation so
if you put this hundred thousand in
there because i'm comfortable with you
doing that um
and it goes down further if you go into
freakout mode because of your current
the because of all the crap you've been
through in the last 36 months
then and you pull it out low then that
was a bad strategy okay
so you've got to ask yourself are you
emotionally
prepared
to ride this market down a little
further if it goes down if you are then
and you're gonna leave it alone five
years i'm putting the money in the
market with your smart investor pro
right if you're not that's okay to say
out loud
you know what i'm at a vulnerable point
right now because i've been through hell
and based on that i don't really want to
ride anything
i'm done with rides i mean
i'm going to put it in a money market i
don't even care if it makes money losing
money scares me a lot more than making
money or the not making money
agreed elsa how much do you have in
savings outside of the hundred thousand
no that's everything okay well i want
you to have a fully funded emergency
fund so let's park some of that because
like you just mentioned with the
recession if something happens to your
job you're gonna have three to six
months of expenses i'd probably lean
towards six months since you're you know
single income and that'll make you feel
real good about then putting the rest in
the market because you've got six months
of expenses sitting there ready to cover
you and you don't have a mortgage
payment so that helps a whole lot
yeah that's the direction i would go for
sure
um
and if you'd if you want to park it in
there you're okay
from a financial analysis exclusively
an investment analysis i would be
comfortable putting the money in there
to leave alone
because i'm comfortable with the market
being down knowing it's going to come up
i'm very comfortable with that but if
you're in a position you need to
remember folks when you're making these
decisions it's not just analyzing the
investment it's analyzing where you are
because personal finance is personal
you know
if you just went through a divorce a
death of a loved one you went through a
uh
very emotional stressful anxiety-ridden
career change
something like that you might not be at
your strongest point in your life you
might be
needing some emotional time off from
being brave right now and that's okay
it's okay to move slowly it's better to
be wise enough to recognize that to be
self-aware
and and not put yourself out there
um a lot of times when people lose money
it has nothing to do with the investment
being bad it's their timing sucks
because of their personal
uh vulnerabilities